[Music]
you ever thought about how old-school
voting is what can I do for you this
afternoon Betty we talked to our doctors
over Skype and meets our soul mates on
an app but when it comes to electing our
next government
we still trudge to the local school and
mark a piece of paper with a tiny pencil
it does results in brilliant students
like this but is our voting system out
of touch this is electronic voting in
three minutes there are different levels
of a voting you could use a computer at
a polling station efficient process this
was usually you'd also either have to
fill in a piece of paper or you'd see a
printout of your vote
this is the system that lots of American
states use or you could vote remotely
over the Internet which is the system
Estonia uses they're the only country in
the world to let everyone vote remotely
in their elections has even been a
suggestion you could vote by text but
research showed voters thought it would
trivialize the election so is Evo ting a
good idea well it could potentially make
the process more secure ballot stuffing
like this brazen example in Russia would
be a thing of the past because voters
would be electronically identified
Somaliland even scans the irises of
voters to make sure they are who they
say they are they're the only country in
the world to do so and the processors
are massively reduce the level of
multiple voting in their elections
but Evo ting comes with its own security
risks most problematically hacking
[Music]
Russian linked hackers are accused of
targeting the election systems of 20
American states during the 2016 election
anyone who's planning any mischief will
be thwarted immediately successfully
breaking into two of the systems Russia
had nothing to do with me winning one
Dutch group even managed to reprogram a
voting computer to play chess showing
how vulnerable the system was security
is the biggest reason Evo ting isn't
widespread across Europe yet the
Netherlands went back to paper and
pencil after 10 years of an electronic
system because of security fears
supporters of electronic voting often
say it increases participation in
elections but there isn't really
evidence to back that up a trial in
Norway showed there was no difference in
voter turnouts and even in Estonia which
saw a huge spike in voter turnout when
they began he voting says the number of
voters have gone back down for Estonians
the novelty value faded fast setting up
electronic voting is not cheap Ireland
spent more than 50 million euros
creating an online voting system only to
decide it wasn't secure enough to use in
an election but the systems need less
stuff on the day for counting and some
groups say it could save the government
up to 18 million pounds per election
that's enough to pay for around 3,800
children's entire primary school
education
the government has commissioned
inquiries into e-voting and even trial
two in Gateshead
as yet we remain a firmly
paper-and-pencil kind of country
[Music]